الأكياس معبأة
ومعبأة وجاهزة للإقلاع
لآلاف الأشخاص في إيرلندا
، أصبح تسليم الطائرات بدون طيار حقيقة واقعة
الآن الشركة التي تقف وراءها تصل
إلى السماء
وستكون المملكة المتحدة سوقًا رئيسيًا لنا في
أوروبا أيضًا ، كما بدأنا في
استئجار  فريق الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، لذلك نتوقع أن نكون
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
للتجربة هذا العام ، بدأت
Manor في تجريب تقنيتها
في بلدتين أيرلنديتين العام الماضي بمهمة
نهائية لاستبدال توصيل الأطعمة والبقالة عبر
الطرق الآن بتكلفة 25 مليون دولار في
تمويل
هذه الشركة الناشئة.  اختبار
للوصول إلى المستوى التالي ،
لدينا زوج من الأبواب يمكننا في
الواقع فتحه. تقوم الشركة التي تتخذ من دبلن مقراً
لها
بتصنيع أسطولها من
الطائرات بدون طيار ذاتية القيادة هنا في ويلز
بضغطة زر واحدة يعدون
بالوصول إلى وجهتهم
حتى في الظروف المعاكسة  أحوال الطقس
لا يمكننا التخطيط لكل سيناريو ولكن
الحقيقة هي أننا نبني زيادات عن الحاجة
لجميع الأشياء التي قد لا
نتوقعها ، دعنا نقول أننا تعرضنا
لحادث غريب نتعرض له  عن طريق البرق ،
لدينا نظام مظلات يمكن
نشره بشكل مستقل عن
بقية الطائرة بحيث يسقط الطائرة
بطريقة آمنة وخاضعة للرقابة ، وكان الشيء الوحيد الذي
لم تخطط
له Mana هو cobot 19. عندما ضرب الوباء
الشركة كان  تم إجبارها على التحول بسرعة
وفي تجربتها الأولى حولت
قاعدة عملائها من طلاب الجامعات
إلى أولئك الذين يعزلون أنفسهم ويحتاجون إلى
الرعاية الطبية والإمدادات
يعتقد الرئيس التنفيذي لبوب هيلي أن الوباء
يمكن أن يكون بمثابة تعزيز للثقة العامة
في الطائرات بدون طيار.
لقد اضطر كل كيان كبير والمجتمع ككل
إلى إعادة التفكير في
ما هو طبيعي وهذا أمر جيد لتوصيل الأدوية
بدون طيار وكان له ميزة واضحة
أثناء الوباء فهو الاتصال المجاني
كما أنه يمكّن الشركات المحلية من
خدمة العملاء
بسرعات قياسية لا تقبل المنافسة لتناول القهوة.
مقهى إلى عتبة الباب أو في حالتي حقل
في أقل من ثلاث دقائق ، المقهى الذي
يعتمد على مانا لتوزيع
منتجاته هو  omas and co في جزيرة أورنمور
يقول مالكها إنه على الرغم من بعض
المخاوف الأولية ، فقد أتت الشراكة ثمارها ، كنت
قلقًا بشأن إرسال طعام ساخن لإرسال
المشروبات إلى السماء وتعلم أن شيئًا ما
قد ينسكب أو أن شيئًا ما قد يسقط
من الطائرة بدون طيار
ولكنني لم أستطع '  لقد كنت مخطئًا أكثر
عندما أحدثت خدمة توصيل الطائرات بدون طيار
فرقًا كبيرًا في أعمالنا
، فليس فقط المتاجر المحلية
تعمل مع سلاسل كبيرة مثل tesco
وتناول الطعام فقط
وتأمل في التوسع ولكن على الرغم من
التكنولوجيا المتقدمة
قد تكون هناك غيوم على  في الأفق ،
سنقوم
برحلات ملايين الرحلات الجوية يوميًا ، وهذا أكبر
من أي شركة طيران تراها في أي وقت مضى ،
لذا لنعرف أن العديد من الرحلات الجوية
تتم بشكل لا تشوبه
شائبة وهندسة منتج للوصول إلى هذا
المستوى من الموثوقية
أمر صعب للغاية  شركة
تغتنم كل فرصة وتجعل التسليم بالطائرة بدون طيار
أقرب إلى عتبة داركم